[Music]
everybody it's Charlie I had a chance to
see venom this is gonna be my
non-spoilery review of the movie I'll
talk about the good the bad the ugly and
how things have changed you know
compared to say the previous version of
Venom's that we got during the original
Tobey Maguire spider-man films I'm still
doing that giveaway for the spider-man
ps4 game all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a venom
related comment on the video I'll name a
new winner at the end of this so there
are a couple important things that we
really need to talk about specific to
this movie does the movie work off on
its own without spider-man the MCU
like does this venom verse work is what
they establish in the movie strong
enough to merit the trilogy that they
have planned because Tom Hardy was
signed for three movies not just this
one movie it isn't strong enough for
Sony to use it as the backbone of its
own interconnected MCU style universe
like we have the Morbius movie that's
coming up the silk movie there's a Night
Watch a jackpot movie black cat silver
sable movies so no question about it as
it wound up Tom Hardy is probably one of
the only people in the world that could
have pulled this off he's a fantastic
actor the way they filmed the venom
scenes are actually really interesting
like he actually did the voice for the
venom character and for Eddie Brock but
because of the way they did the special
effects he would actually just walk
around on set in his normal costuming
and talked to himself with a special
earpiece so I'll talk about that in a
second because there are some weird
tonal mismatch issues when they get to
certain parts of the movie but when he
fully becomes venom he is totally on
point so just on a sheer conceptual
level the character totally works vastly
vastly better than the Topher Grace
version of venom from the Tobey Maguire
films there was probably never any
question in your mind about that like no
matter what the movie was going to be
like after that first trailer you just
look at it and say this is gonna be the
version of venom that people will
remember will just forget about that old
version which is funny because avi arad
said that he accepted full blame for
original venom during Tobey Maguire era
but he's also the producer of this venom
movie so it's not really clear what his
creative involvement with the project
was but they have a great cast
Riz Ahmed Michelle Williams all
fantastic actors they all feel like they
know that they're in a much more
hardcore movie even though the
said that the whole time they always
planned it to be pg-13 based on things
that they said really early in the
process and the way it was pitched it
sounded like they did originally intend
for it to be rated R so that's the way
it was written and then they just turned
it into a pg-13 movie during the Edit so
one of the problems with the film I
think is during the transitional process
where Eddie starts to get the symbiote
in there having that bargaining stage
where he's not really sure if he's on
board for what the symbiote is offering
him and he kind of goes through this
weird Woody Allen place where he gets
really idiosyncratic and it gets kind of
silly in a way that doesn't necessarily
match the tone of the rest of the film
but a lot of those problems go away once
they get to the we are venom of it all
so the funny thing recently you may have
heard Tom Hardy talking about deleted
scenes he said that he improvised maybe
like nine hours worth of material so
that might be where some of these
back-and-forth weird tonal issues come
from when he's talking to the symbiote
initially considering that you really
only have that last spider-man three
venom appearance to compare the special
effects to this is light-years beyond so
the weird way they did this is that
instead of doing it Tom Holland style
where Tom Hardy would wear a motion
capture suit and they would fix it in
special effects later he would actually
just walk around and it's almost like
they photoshopped the symbiote on top of
him
so like the way you see it form around
him he was filmed that scene with just
him in it and then later they would add
all the symbiote stuff in
post-production with like very few
reference points so no special man
cancelling suit required which is what
Mark Ruffalo calls the suit that he
wears when he's doing motion capture for
the Hulk compared to a movie like
spider-man homecoming which is connected
to the MCU then it feels like a very
small self-contained movie but like I
said Sony is planning for a trilogy
there are two post-credit scenes so make
sure you stay through the end credit
there's a mid credit scene in a
post-credits scene that do some
world-building that set up the obvious
sequel you know typical expectation of a
Marvel movie even though it's a Sony
Marvel movie if you're a fan of comic
book movies or of the venom character of
our comics in general then you have a
pretty good idea based on what you see
during the end of the movie where
they're headed with the sequence pretty
clear but I don't think it quite does
enough job to set it up if you're not a
comic book fan so don't be surprised if
you go with some of your family members
and
have no idea what's going on that is
largely I think the fault of the script
so they have amazing actors the special
effects are actually pretty decent and
we know that Tom Hardy is a verified
fantastic actor so the weakest thing
about the film is the script it did feel
like they kind of rushed it into
production last year like they announced
the venom movie and they said oh yeah by
the way we're gonna be releasing it next
October and when I heard that I was just
like how are they gonna turn a movie
like that around that fast it takes them
two years to make one of Tom Hollands
spider-man movies and that's still Sony
releasing that film so if you've been
reading the news and you're hearing
critics talk about the movie I feel like
a lot of the issues that they're talking
about are just due to them trying to
rush the movie out so quickly obviously
there are a lot of Easter eggs for
spider-man stuff but without getting
into further spoilers yes the movie can
work as it exists by itself in this
venom verse that they're trying to
create but they just need to have a
really solid script to give to the
actors but you know special effects
everything else about it is totally fine
I feel like there are a couple things
that people are just having fun with
there will be a lot of memes after this
movie comes out but like Dark Knight
Rises was divisive when it came out
people turned Tom Hardy's Bane and his
voice into a meme this film won't be
divisive like Batman V Superman or
Justice League was divisive but you will
probably see a lot of critics having
fistfights on Twitter about it is a
villain Riz Ahmed and riot I think we're
a little more consistent you know
they're probably about as worthy as a
foe that they could give venom in a
movie like this without getting to the
bigger comic book stuff that they're
trying to build towards in the sequel so
no spoilers for that like I said
post-credit scenes stay to the end of
the movie you'll know exactly what's
going on but the movie itself is in no
danger of dethroning Marvel's spider-man
Tom Holland films is the crown jewel of
Sony's film universe so if you were
going into venom worried that Sony might
have this new franchise on its hands and
it'll steal Tom Holland away and not
renew its deal with Marvel I don't think
after watching venom there is any danger
of that they might have some successes
with the 900 characters that they have
the rights to but I think they're always
going to need Marvel creative you'll
come out of this very thankful for the
structure in the organization in the
quality that come with Marvel movies
like you always have certain
expectations you kind of know what
you're getting going into it and there
are just certain parts of venom that are
really weird it didn't ruin the movie
for me but just be sure to couch your
expectations I don't expect this to be
the greatest spider-man movie that
you've ever seen in the history of the
world so final grade I'll say like BB -
like they did a really good job they
just rushed it out a little bit quicker
spend some more time on the script for
the sequel I think it will totally do
well enough to merit that sequel and yes
they can do a venom verse if they want
but I think the whole idea is is that
Sony really wants to use Tom Holland in
one of its movies in the future so we'll
just have to wait and see what happens
with that there's all kinds of box
office projections I'll talk a little
bit about that as I do Easter Egg videos
post credit scene videos all the normal
stuff that I would do for Marvel movies
leave your requests in the comments
below and once you have a chance to see
the movie let me know in the comments
what you think of this new version of
venom Matt flavin congratulations you're
the giveaway winner from my last big
video please email me on the about page
of my channel so I can get your contact
details click here to watch that new
Mysterio scene from spider-man far from
home and click here for that new
spider-verse trailer with the Tobey
Maguire and Andrew Garfield moments
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]
you